- Well, congrats on the Vegas show.
I know a lot of artists, me included,
we just love performing
and we were all just,
we had to stop for like
a year or two. Right?
So how is it to back to be?
- I thought it would be
different, but I mean,
it was like these 18
months just disappeared
and we were back on the stage
and it looked, it felt pretty
much the same as usual.
There was one extra element
on these last couple of shows
that we did, that I'd never felt before.
It felt,
yeah they were applauding.
Yeah, we were all having a good time,
but there was something else.
It felt like the audience was
grateful to be in this room
and not have to worry about all the crap
that we've been dealing with.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They were laughing
and singing and happy.
And I felt like everybody
was just very grateful.
They were applauding me,
but they were applauding themselves.
- The moment. No, we took
it for granted a little.
I was just having this
conversation yesterday with someone
because I literally,
I mean shows started happening
and my friends, we have been to four.
So we're going to one next week.
Like, I get drunk off the energy of it.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
You're like, I miss it.
I didn't know that I miss,
I don't even really miss
performing as much as I do watching
and like being a part
of the show in that way.
That's so amazing. And it's
awesome to listen to music,
but to feel it,
- Yes.
- and to be in a room filled
with people that you would
probably never find yourself
in the same room with in
any other circumstance
- So it's not having to
worry about everything else
that we've been worrying about 18 months.
- [Kelly] Escapism. Yeah.
- It just disappeared for 90 minutes
and I was grateful I could
do it, but it really,
they were grateful, I was grateful.
It was a great couple of nights.
- Yeah. Yeah. I love that.
I love seeing shows.
You've also got your own musical, right?
I think that's amazing.
And it's got to sound incredible.
You're such a great pianist
and musician and writer.
- Yeah. this is the biggest
and the most important thing to me.
Right now, it's a musical called "Harmony"
and it opens in New York,
down at the Yiddish Theater
and the little hope it goes
from there to Broadway.
It's called "Harmony."
And it opens in April,
this coming year and
previews start before that,
and you should check this one out.
It's a real good one.
- It takes a while for all
these projects to develop.
So how long have you been working on this?
- [Barry] 20 years.
- 20 years? Wow.
- [Audience] Wow.
- Yeah. Yeah, but it's worth it.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- You really need to check this one out.
- Oh, that's amazing.
So what's "Harmony?" What is it about?
Like, what's the gist.
- It's about a singing group
that was very, very big
in the 1920s in Germany.
A few of them were Jews
and a few of them were not,
and their story.
The reason we don't know who they are,
they were called the Comedian Harmonists,
very talented, very talented,
tremendously popular.
And we don't know about them
because everything they did was destroyed.
- Oh, so this is based
off of something real.
I didn't get that.
- A real story.
It's a real story and it's very compelling
and I'm very proud of the score.
And my partner, Bruce Sussman,
wrote the lyrics and the book.
And it's really deep and
funny, because they were funny,
but you really should check this one out.
- Wow. I can't wait to see that.
That was a great sell by the way.
(Barry laughing)
I'm like, wow!
I'm going to get you to
sell my stuff. Like, I'm in.
And that's the thing too,
like, New York starting to come back.
I miss shows so much.
We opened this whole show
in New York this year.
- [Barry] I know it's rough.
- Oh, man. But it's such a city
that feels ghost-like without theater.
- You know, Bruce told me when
we were in the middle of it,
times square was empty.
All the streets that had
the theaters on it, empty.
Like, you know, newspapers
just floating around
like some something out
of a science fiction.
- [Kelly] Like a movie, yeah.
- Yeah. It was rough.
- Oh, well you have new
fans on TikTok as well,
which I love,
because this lip sync video
of "Mandy" went viral.
Here it is, you've got to see it.
- [Barry] Did you see it?
♪ I see a memory ♪
♪ I never realized ♪
♪ How happy you made me ♪
♪ Oh, Mandy ♪
♪ Well, you came and you
gave without taking ♪
- Oh, my God. He's adorable.
So what did you think when you saw that?
- Well, I was surprised.
I wondered how did he find
"Mandy" to lip-sync to.
He's so young.
- Spotify is a beautiful thing.
I feel like we find things
like on all these streaming services now,
like even my kids are
starting to listen to music.
They're like, "oh, I love this new song."
I'm like, "that ain't new,
that's from the '80s."
- You should show them "Copacabana."
They would love "Copacabana."
- I know, I'm just saying
they find this music
and they think it's new. Yeah.
- I wonder how he found the.
- Backstory. We need the backstory.
Well, the video inspired
thousands of responses
like this one.
♪ I see a memory ♪
♪ I never realized ♪
♪ How happy you made me ♪
♪ Oh, Mandy ♪
♪ Well, you came and you
gave without taking ♪
(Kelly laughing)
- Wait, wait, wait.
And this one.
♪ I see a memory ♪
♪ I never realized ♪
♪ How happy you made me ♪
♪ Oh, Mandy ♪
♪ Well, you came and you
gave without taking ♪
(laughing)
- So have you heard from that kid?
Have you heard from who
made the first video?
- Oh, no. No, I haven't.
- Oh my God. It's so great.
And it's so random,
which is the most amazing
part and the reactions.
Anyway, well we've reached out to him
and he's actually in our audience.
So say hello to William White!
(audience cheering)
There he is.
He's in the middle screen.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
Well, meet Barry Manilow!
- [Barry] Hi. Hi.
- Hi, Barry.
- How did you find the song?
- Yeah, it was my dad. He showed me.
He's a huge fan, so he's pretty jealous
that I'm on here right now,
but his buddies love it.
So we go for walks and he
showed me some old music
and then I found "Mandy",
and I was like, "oh, this is
like perfect for the ladies."
Like, it's a heartthrob music.
I was like, all right.
So I went home and after
work, I was landscaping,
and went home and started
making "Mandy" videos.
And from there it just blew up,
like over one weekend I hit
like 1.8 million followers.
- That's amazing.
- Talk about getting laid from music.
- I know. I'm just
saying, that song lasts.
- [Barry] You must have scored.
- Some longevity with that song.